from the tampa bay times rick stroud
back here on the rich eisen show how you
doing rick
i'm doing well rich how are you i'm
doing fine the general sense around
there is what right now
well the wheels kind of came off uh
you're gonna have to get some guys back
healthy that's for sure i mean you know
the people that tom brady relied on
chris godwin mike evans leonard
fournette that trio is gonna miss some
time and um don't know how much time
certainly they i think they expect them
all back by the playoffs
but you know look new orleans has his
number in the buck's number they've won
seven in a row in the regular season
against his franchise
they're you know tom brady's own four in
the regular season they got him when it
counted and there's no question about
that we can talk about that game if you
want to as well but at the end of the
day this defense for new orleans
um
has has tom brady's number and the
buck's number and it doesn't seem to
matter if uh
sean payton's coaching or kevin james or
dennis allen you know none of that
matters they're gonna beat their ass and
that's sort of what has gone on here
it's been two score defeats these games
haven't been close
um and to see a shutout i think you know
was most shocking and even before those
players went out they were putting up
the bagels so
yeah it's it's uh was not a good outcome
for them so you say they're gonna miss
time all three of them walk me through
what your sense of it right now is
rick stroud
i think chris godwin's probably the most
serious uh he's got a an mcl sprain
they're doing an mri on him today
haven't decided yet if he's going on ir
there's only three games remaining so if
they thought he was going to miss the
rest of regular season they would do so
but they're waiting for some some you
know doctors to evaluate that
i think that mike evans
has a chance to come back before the
season's over i don't know if he'll play
this week you know those hamstrings are
very tricky
but from what i understand his isn't as
serious as uh
you know as as maybe uh godwin's injury
is and then we'll just see with leonard
fournette he went into the game with a
bad wheel he had an ankle he didn't
practice during the week much
they're fortunate they got ronald jones
who hasn't you know played much at all
this year maybe he'll be this year's you
know lombardi lenny or playoff lenny you
know and and the tables have turned and
he'll get the chance to to carry the
rock now the rest of the way but um you
know those are the three guys and gronk
who had a horrendous day
that tom brady has leaned on during that
five-game winning streak to put them in
position that they were in but they
weren't able to close the deal so
a little sobering a little hurting right
now in tampa so um this would be music
to green bay's ears that's for sure is
it possible that the bucks
just figure out um
we we can't push the pedal to the metal
for the one seed you know we won it from
the
from the wild card position last year
and we should be able to beat carolina
at least once and the jets
with whoever we put out there and let
the chips fall where they may seeds two
through four is that maybe the way they
go about their business the last three
weeks of the season
well i mean i you know what i found is
that especially with bruce's team they
don't hold the pieces back they push him
out there for every game
because you know you're talking about
seedings they drop down to the number
three seed because dallas in a three-way
tie has the best conference record for
now but they can still get back to the
number two i think the the top seed
dreams are long gone green bay not going
to lose two games even if they went out
um so they're probably looking at best
uh two home playoff games and then
they'd have to go back into the frozen
tundra which they've done and there'd be
a lot of pressure on green bay of course
to win it but you can't count on no fans
like they had or 9 000 fans and a
bombing 34 degree day like they had a
year ago so
that's the best case scenario is that
they somehow
win these last three and uh arizona and
dallas lose a game and they somehow get
back to that number two seat but
there's no question they hurt themselves
last night and they're going to take a
tougher road
in the playoffs when they get there
assuming they win one of these they just
need to win one to win the nfc south and
get get one game at home anyway tampa
eight times rick stroud here on the rich
eisen show so uh two stories that uh you
broke uh by the way congrats on that and
uh your hard work it's not just you
covering the tampa bay buccaneers uh one
in particular though uh involves a buck
and the fake vaccination card and all
that business with antonio brown i
couldn't help but notice that we heard
from michelle tafoya during the game
last night that the uh the bucks were
going to welcome him back that he was
not going to be sent packing uh despite
his uh behavior is the only word for it
why what happened there rick
this is before by the way the injuries
this is before everyone got hurt at the
position last night so yeah well yeah
certainly their opinion hasn't changed
now right um you know and and so much
for the you know the last strike thing
that bruce arian said when he when he
signed antonio brown it turns out that
tom brady is the umpire
not bruce arians and tom brady wants you
know antonio brown back on this football
team he's going to come back and he you
know he's needed now more than ever
um for tom to to continue on and win
these games and
uh you know
anytime we asked bruce about it
especially last night after the game he
said you know those guys did their time
they deserve a chance to come back
um look they get paid to win games and
it's unfortunate that brown you know has
had these problems in the past and been
selfish in in this case it was a very
dangerous situation you know everybody
the one thing i think people forget
about the story is that he actually did
get covet in week two
and missed the week three game in los
angeles which means he was sitting there
unvaccinated around people like bruce
arians who's immune compromised as a
three-time cancer survivor around guys
like tom moore who's in his 80s
and could have gotten somebody very sick
or worse and
you know what influence if any he had on
a guy like mike edwards who's never been
in trouble we don't know but they've
certainly missed uh you know with the
injuries they've had they missed mike
the last three weeks as well
but these guys will come back in here
they'll be welcomed by their team
obviously they need them
in these games coming up and
i just think that's that's the bottom
line you know uh they're not going to
say no to tom they're not going to say
that brown has to test the packet if
they're going to do that it was pretty
obvious when he was suspended they would
have done it right away you know it
wouldn't have been one of these deals
where well we'll we'll decide that uh
and kick the can down the road for three
weeks so we've always known he's coming
back and um and he'll be in the lineup
and and probably see a lot of targets on
on sunday at carolina yeah so he's back
this is it he's coming back and he's
gonna play on sunday and
you know uh football wise i mean what a
what an absolute godsend that is you
know i mean yeah as much as i i find it
reprehensible what he did
lying about his vaccination status um
you know football wise certainly with
evans and godwin out and we saw what it
looked like last night without fournette
as well is there another kid anywhere in
a practice squad that might come up and
kind of dominate we're seeing all these
kids on the detroit lions make most of
opportunities i'm wondering if there's
anybody uh honestly we see it around the
league tyler huntley uh for the ravens
who else might be there that we we need
to check out for the bucks over the next
three weeks i think i think they're
fortunate you know um the guy
you remember just a week ago uh won the
game in overtime the 58 yard touchdown
bro for shard parriman
is somebody that had a tremendous final
month of the season in 2019 with james
winston right
had about 500 yards in his in his last
four games and bruce arians remembered
that um you know he had been with two
teams
this year the lions and the bears didn't
play him at all
and i think brady um took a liking to
him he's a bigger body guy he's
incredibly explosive um you know from a
a speed standpoint so they'll get him
back off the covet list he was unable to
play this week
and really it's just time on task you
know
brady has been so focused on
really just those you know four or five
guys have been playing every week you
know obviously the two top receivers
evan scotland he got gronk back who was
a big target for him although he had his
worst game since he's been here and then
and then leonard fournette has been
doing everything so
because of that you know these guys
don't get many reps in practice so we
haven't seen o.j howard at all this year
we haven't seen cam bray except very
sparingly we didn't see scottie miller
at all he was inactive a week ago when
perriman was playing um so you know
they're going to use this week at
practice to get the rhythm and the and
the timing and everything and the trust
back with those guys uh and obviously he
has it in brown who i would think would
be a very busy man you know depending on
how much of a load um he usually keeps
himself in shape that ankle's supposed
to be better so heavy work day for him
coming up for sure but
that's it and then maybe keyshawn vaughn
who's a running back that you know
didn't make very many plays and they put
him in some key situations because quite
frankly rojo got tired you know he was
gassed i mean he's not in not in game
shape when he ran that 30-yard run
they had some critical downs after that
and vaughn had to go in and he hasn't
played all year
maybe 1920 snaps so these guys are here
for a reason and they're going to have
to get ready and play and play at a high
level rick stroud tampa bay times here
on the rich eisen show so uh brady
making comments to sports illustrated in
the sports person of the year award uh
article that went along with it i mean
i i might be the only guy talking about
it but when i see brady talk about that
winning's a relief that that's the
general sense that's those are the words
that i normally hear from somebody
that's that's thinking
uh about
more than just playing football to be
honest with you um and that's all we
believe that brady does think about and
we all look at him and think he can play
the 50. what's the sense around there
right now about him they're just
thinking it's this this is just another
year and he's under contract he's going
to be back is there any
talk about it well i don't think they
know um definitively you know exactly
what what tom will do
i had been told last year when you know
they signed him to an extension part of
that was was salary cap relief
he's not wedded to that third year after
this season
in any way but
you know i think if he still feels well
physically
uh he he thinks he can do it till he's
at least 45
but there's no guarantee rich i mean you
can play this thing on your head and say
well what you know what if he won
another super bowl with that you know
gisele asked him after the game
in february you know when he won this
super bowl last year
haven't you done enough well of course
he's done enough but he also said in
that si article that you know he he
can't picture himself at home watching
guys play and say and i'm better than
that sop you know i know i could get do
a better job than this guy
so
that that's another part of it and
you know for whatever reason some of the
better players in in sports
they don't know when to leave the party
you would think it'd be the opposite but
i mean michael jordan hung the nets with
a three-pointer and ended up being a
washington wizard so
you know you just you don't know
and and i know he can still play and he
knows he can still play but eventually
you know family matters are going to
dictate what he does and and his wife
and his kids are getting older uh how
much do you want to put them through uh
with the sacrifice because he's all in
you know not just for the six months but
for the full year
this guy doesn't really take many days
off and you know he has some family time
but it's not anything like he's going to
have the problem is once you put those
keys on the table if you're tom brady
you're not picking them up again and
there's nothing he said this as well
there is nothing that is going to
replace what he has done in football the
relationships the locker room uh winning
the thrill of running out of the tunnel
with 75 000 people
you know what else could he do
that that would replicate anything close
to that so he knows you know the
greatest part of his life professionally
will be over so i think he wants to
extend it as long as possible but i i'm
up in the air i have no idea whether
winning losing or anything short of
injury would make him leave the game
before next year
rick stroud tampa bay times uh last one
for you sir uh your piece um
i'll be honest i uh wednesday night i
was at the um the premiere of kurt
warner's new movie curtain brenda
warner's new movie the american underdog
here at los angeles and i come out of
the theater
and um i hear urban meyer is fired
and then i read the story and it's like
after what happened with josh lambo i'm
like what and then i looked at your
story and i read it three times and i'm
like i cannot like what like he kicked a
kicker like and then
asked him the next day when are you
gonna put a smile on that face and it
just struck me as so outrageous
and urban meyer to my colleague ian
rapport has essentially said that's just
not the way it happened so i'll give you
uh the floor on this
rick well josh lambeau you know
contemporaneously reported that to the
jaguars back in august so i don't you
know it wasn't a situation where he just
decided you know let me let me jump on
the pile here while urbanist is you know
taking on water um he he feels for a lot
of people in that jaguars organization
he spent five years there
he's a successful kicker
in his own right and you know the thing
about it is um
what urban meyer even urban meyer you
know in his statement they gave us
uh that i read within um
you know nobody is is disagreeing the
event happened it's just to what degree
you know if we're talking about how hard
he kicked a guy
um that that's not a great argument on
his behalf in my opinion but
um you know when you hear the language
the bullying that goes on you know
not not calling specialists by their
name um you know this sort of
i mean i can only imagine what 18
through 21 year olds you know reacted to
when when they're going through it at
you know bowling green or utah or you
know florida or ohio state but um it
doesn't work at this level with
professionals
and he was his own worst enemy from the
get-go
so it's ironic i think that you know
a specialist uh may have been the last
straw something that happened back in
august but you know all i can say is
when i did the story
they were in crisis mode in jacksonville
uh i had a lot of conversations with
them they begged me to hold the story
till four o'clock
um you know i got a statement from their
legal counsel first
i got uh you know a threatening letter
from his attorney
about publishing the story without
certain information we waited for their
statement
you know and in the end shot khan said
he decided last sunday or sunday before
that to fire him but i don't know why
you fire a guy on a wednesday after you
let him game plan go through a practice
and then disappear
from the meeting so none of this adds up
to me the organization is totally
dysfunctional they turned it over to a
guy
who wasn't capable of making the
transition to the nfl
and he in the end i think he got what he
deserved but
uh it was a it was i'll grant you i went
to bed and when i woke up to see that he
was fired i didn't expect that to happen
that day or that evening but it was a
surprise to me as well yeah so the
timeline was who's lawyer was it the
team's lawyer or urban meyers
urban meyers
so what happened urban meyer's lawyer
reached out to you and well they they
reached out and they you know
it's kind of rich uh rich because they
they wanted to offer up uh you know
a couple of players
uh but only off the record to kawa to
corroborate that he did not kill him
to corroborate not that he didn't kick
him
but the to the degree of which he kicked
him
and i you know i was willing to speak to
them my editor decided since you know
it's funny because the whole
during this whole drip drip process you
know everybody was using sources and you
know well who are these people and if i
catch the source he's gone tomorrow and
this sort of stuff that you'd hear from
the jaguars organization then when their
guys under fire they want to offer up
you know unnamed sources and players
that
you know will back back to coach and
which is fine
except that this was a a guy that showed
enough courage to put his name
on on the incident and was willing to
speak on the record um but irman's urban
statement which was included in our
report said that there were witnesses
that would back his story but again the
ones i talked to
all we were talking about is the degree
to which he kicked him not that he
didn't kick him
so
you know
that's a matter of interpretation but
overall it wasn't one thing it might
have been the last thing but they knew
about it since august so i don't know
how
shot khan and firing him for cause and
all that's going to play out but i give
josh lambeau credit for telling his
story telling his truth and being very
honest as he could be about it
and you know in the end the results are
what they were so you're saying to me
rick stroud and everybody here that
based on your
personal experience
urban meyer's final hours as the head
coach the jacksonville jaguars at
involved
communicating
[Music]
you through his lawyer in sometimes
threatening manner and also offering up
players so he's also spending his final
moments as the jacksonville jaguars head
coach asking players or
identifying players or trying to reach
out to players to say hey
will you unnamed source talk to this
reporter from the tampa bay times to
talk about how
i really didn't kick josh lambeau very
hard back in august that's you that's
that's what you're saying his final
hours part of which were spent yeah he
he he came off the practice field his
coaches didn't know why he wasn't in the
meetings after that they were in
complete scramble mode since 8 30 in the
morning of that wednesday i so yeah the
time that urban spent when he wasn't
working with the team was consulting his
representatives
who were then calling me
i spoke numerous times to people about
the details of the story providing them
with everything i had
they wanted an extension before we
published till 4 p.m
we delayed it until 4 30
and they were in scramble mode and that
just doesn't sound like a guy that the
owner had fired on sunday to me
so
you know to what extent
that contributed to it i saw the
reaction to the people you know to the
story from people maybe that had some
impact but but urban meyer was solely
focused on keeping his job
um because of lambo's comments and they
had plenty of advanced notice about what
that story would say
and you know they were just trying to
refute it as best they could but no one
said that he didn't kick him uh you know
that's that's the interesting part
um so that's that's all i can say about
it but
yeah it was quite a quite a wednesday
afternoon all right so you've been
covering the nfl how long again rick how
long have you been covering that uh long
time rich
so where does this rank uh where does
this one rank for you
where does it run it's a weird one you
know uh
yeah uh-huh it's just not often you'll
you know you'll write a story i mean
i've had a couple weeks where you know
um
got beat up pretty good by people after
the antonio brown story and two weeks
later 15 days later three guys got
suspended
um wrote a josh lambeau story and
urban meyer got fired the next morning
so the miami dolphins are not looking
for me to walk into their building
i can tell you that but uh
no you know
you don't like to see people lose their
jobs and it's it's part of our job yes
you know to just uh report and and and
be very careful with
you know with with what we say or what
we allow other people to say and we're
for the record paper
um so everything we have written about
both instances or people that are
willing to put their name on it we
didn't source anything
and you know i'm very i'm proud of the
work we do at the tampa bay times and
you know other people like the nfl and
shad khan and those guys made those
decisions not me but
um but i think they were important
stories and
i'm glad we got him rick stroud you're
the man thanks again for your time here
on this busy monday we'll we'll we'll
catch up down the road have a happy
holiday you and yours same to you rich
thanks for having me you bet at nfl
stroud on twitter i follow him you
should do a must follow
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here